hello everyone and welcome to a very
weird game from the 2019 Riga Feder
Grand Prix it's a shocker mamita versus
West so this is Game one of the classics
so we are in the semi-finals and well as
you've seen if you've been covered
watching my short coverage or if you've
been following the live feed West's has
been playing really well lately and
Momotaro he's had a few shaky
tournaments but he did get a son so you
know it's to be expected you have to get
used to new things in life so this game
it's gonna be really weird I I'm warning
you
before that let's just check two photos
from this matchup so here it is here is
Mahmoud yaar of just you know saying I'm
cool with that line you know I know it
pretty well
don't don't really care and here's a
nice close-up of Wesley are trying to
figure out if Mammadov really knows the
line well or if maybe he's just bluffing
mmm but I don't want to over build the
suspenseful is to just check out the
game
mama Tara with the white pieces opens
with d4 and of course you all know where
this is going Knight of 6 c4 e6 knight
of 3 and B 5 we have the Queens gambit
declined but here mom yah goes for g3 he
wants he prefers a cattle and set up in
this game Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to
G to think arrow in the lights work
bishop with castles by Wesley and
castles by mama D ro D captures on c4
and now Knight to e5 and the Wesley goes
for Knight to c6 the famous Triple C
pawn variation with Knight captures B
captures and now Knight to a3 white
wouldn't mind grabbing one of these
pawns and getting the knight to a much
nicer square but here Bishop captures on
a3
it's the mostly played move in this line
and pawn captures so if you look at this
position you might think everything you
know about chess is just wrong black has
tripled pawns you already gave up a
bishop pair how can black even play this
well you'll see practice shows that it
is possible to play this position well
without a problem with black so to most
standard ideas here as the black white
is controlling this beautiful diagonal
already threatened to capture on c6
black will either go
the d5 here just plays the night to do a
much nicer square or as in this game
Bishop to a6 so you can give up this c6
pawn but like we said it's a triple C
pawn you don't really want to waste a
move grabbing one of the pawns you'll be
able to you know gobble them up any time
throughout the game so what do you do
here here at mommy they'll place Queen
to d2 and it is a strange move why would
you block your Bishop like this
the problem is mama Dara wants to play
Queen to d2 and Queen to a5 to attack
this Bishop the problem is if you try
and do it with Queen to a4 then black
gets to move the bishop with an attack
on the Queen so black will not be
wasting any time you will not have to
move your queen and then like gets to
play whatever he wants and the a7 phone
is still protected
so with this Queen to d2 idea white
shifts the move to black and now black
has to make a move so Ruby 8 it's a
useful move the beef file is already
open and only now Queen to a5 and now
you don't really have the option of
playing Bishop to b5 anymore because now
a4 just travels the bishop so here Luke
to b8 is in preparation of rook to b6
blacks plan is to play something like
Queen these six to get the rook over to
be eight double up rooks on the B file
and then slowly but surely start pushing
the past C pawn now all this might seem
very weird why did black have tripled C
pawn why why isn't white reacting to
this why is he allowing black to have
the tripled C pawn the past pawn on c4
but you know practice showed that it's
it's perfectly fine with a 4 by white
and now Queen to b6 capturing and d4 is
giving White's too much activity if you
capture on d4 then Bishop to a3 attacks
the rook and here you might consider
giving up an exchange which pawn to c3
start pushing your passed pawn but if
this was any good someone would already
have played it your other option is to
just move the rook you can't go to d8
because rook d1 would just be terrible
for you so you play something like this
and then rook f d1 kicks away the Queen
and you have so much advantage look at
the bishop pair here the Queen controls
this rank the rook slices the board in
half it's just or you know all-around
control for white so Wesley continues
with Queen d6 is the main move in this
position
and here what what is Wesley planning
Wesley wants to get the rock over to b8
he wants to double up Brooks on the B
file also Queen before is an option you
might want to try and force a queen
trade and here there are a couple of
games that reach this position I think
eight of them where he four is played
threatening a five or just Quintus e3
getting the Queen away far away from
this Queen before threat and also
strengthening the the d4 pawn but here
mama Dara played a new move he played a
three he just says okay you can play
whatever you want put black I'm not
allowing your queen to be 4 and let's
just see what you play so of course all
blacks pieces are doing something in the
queen is very nicely centralized the
rook is guarding the bishop you don't
really want to move the bishop as you're
gonna lose the a7 pawn the knight is on
a nice square at some point it's gonna
come to d5 but you still need to develop
your rook so rook F to b8 doubling rooks
on the B file and only now mama Yara was
four efore threatening be five but here
Wesley played something very interesting
he played c3
which makes sense it's a passed pawn you
want to push her passed pawns passed
pawns must be pushed and also it comes
with an attack against the rook on f1
but this move isn't only bad it's it
loses the game so feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out what Wesley
missed in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds it's the move we
already discussed as so congratulations
because I know all of you found it it's
'if I've and Wesley just missed it for
some reason now it's very interesting
how would such a strong player like
Wesley miss such a move well I think
it's just a case of over preparation as
sometimes even my mogera we've covered a
game not so long ago he suffered a case
over preparation where he played a
brilliant game up until move 23 but all
all those moves were engine lines and
then when he had to make the first move
from his head then he just collapsed
so here Wesley pretty much did the same
thing he played every top move and then
when he had to start playing games you
know using his using his own head then
he just blundered
I'm sure c3 is a move that is played in
a lot of the lines that he prepared but
it's not played here and I don't know
this often happens to you it's one of
the reason why I never enjoyed over
preparing games because then it's very
hard to shift into this mode where
you're playing you know theory moves
where you're safe safe from any
dangerous because you know you're safe
and then when you have to make a move by
yourself it just goes downhill from
there so here of course you have to
react your queen is under attack and now
you will have to give up two pieces for
the rook we have Queen to d8 and I'll
eat captures on f6 and now there's no
better move other than to capture the
rook that is why you played c3 with
Bishop captures an f1 Bishop captures an
f1 and now c2 and okay Wester already
has a passed pawn and c2 but still
it's two bishops for a rook and the
bishop pairs will easily a fight off a
queen let alone a rook so I haven't seen
the entry after the game but I don't
know I really don't think that this lion
is something Wesley prepared at home
especially not for a classical game
maybe if it was blitz maybe but I don't
know if this is something Wesley
prepared for for a classical game
against Muhammad Arif and worst of all
rook a to just picks up the pawn you
can't really defend the past pawn so
Queen d5 Wesley now offers a queen trade
as the rockin a2 is under attack so you
do have to react to this and Medea of
trades although it seems like you have
to trade but you really don't you also
can play Queen to d2 a very interesting
move and now if white captures then
Queen to g5 threatening mate and of
course if if just g6 then Queen to h6
fall by Queen g7 mate and here it's just
a game loss for black you have to start
running away but it will not help you
just you know some check here capture
here and well slowly but surely you will
checkmate the black King not even going
to show the line as it's just you know
game over for black so Mammadov would
have probably played the Queen to d2 if
this was the only winning line but
Mamedov is very confident that he will
beat Wesley in this endgame so he just
straight wins we have secret force on d5
rook
actress on c2g captures on f6 and now
rook captures on c7 so it's two bishops
for a rook and the Wesley showed in the
game where he defeated Sarah Kerrigan
that two bishops are even sometimes even
even stronger than a queen so a rope
will have a little chance of fending off
any of those bishops so what's left to
do is to get the King to safety and to
get those bishops fully operational so
let's see how mama Dara will do this
first
Wesley offers a trade Mammadov declines
this and now King the g7 starting to
bring the King into the game mama dog
does the same we have looked to be won
and now just Bishop to b5 disconnecting
the rooks and now how are you getting
this rook into the game it's not gonna
be easy
yes you can play rook a 1 to a 2 but
still the bishop covers this square root
covers this where a bishop covers d2 as
well the light square bishop covers this
square you don't really have a way of
getting this rook back into the game so
now white can pretty much improve his
position as much as he wants until he
decides if he will let the rook into the
game so rooked a 1 by Wesley but still
that rook is not getting into the game
rook the c3 we have looked a b6 and now
Bishop f4 here mama deriv allows it but
with a with an idea he he does have some
plans of trapping this rook here but
also he has plans of rook to c7 followed
by Bishop here which will be very
dangerous for the black king so first
look the b7 getting not allowing a
momager of this rook rook to c7 left but
still if if you want you can play it and
trade but mama Daryl doesn't he just
starts bringing his King into the game
with rook to d1 now threatening the d4
pawn but now Bishop to e3 just defending
it rogue back to be one and now kink the
g4 we have roped the h1 attacking the h2
pawn but now upon 2 H for King to g6 and
now just Bishop back to b3 and now the
thing we discussed the bishops are now
fully operational you have to defend
with f5 defending from check and
delivering check himself King to f3 rook
to d1 by Wesley and now
g4 and it was in this position on move
34 that Wesley so resigned the game he
resigned because there's
very little to do here slowly but surely
you will lose this game you have to play
something let's say King g7 you will
just capture a pawn here captures
captures and now you have so many
options how to win this game you can
just go look here followed by check
maybe rook who goes here then it's a one
idea there is maybe just bring the King
over here and then bring the bishop in
bring the rook somewhere and well while
you're doing all that black doesn't
really have any any good moves so Wesley
knows this and after g4 he resigned the
game which is very weird that we we just
said Wesley had a really awesome
undefeated streak I don't know how long
it was but it was very long in classical
time format and then he just gives it up
because he still thought that he was
still in you know protected waters of
theory were in fact he wasn't a mom
you're introduced a new move here a
three and Wesley just played c3 probably
one of the lines that works in every
other line except in this one that Mommy
they are played which is really strange
and that's why over preparing is very
dangerous and you should always be very
careful when you do it in wrong games
because it's very hard to switch you
know into thinking at least for me sure
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
tough break for Wesley but he still has
one more classical game to get back to
mommy Java and you know not get knocked
out of the feet of Grand Prix so still
you know it's anyone's game anyone can
reach the finals Wesley has the white
pieces and you won't know how dangerous
Wesley is with white I would like to
thank Petrus are they honest Cornell is
one ginsburg and firkin ruse to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
on my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
continue the Capablanca saga covering
the feeder Grand Prix and of course
checking up on your suggestions thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day